in northern Vanina humans revered dogs
for their loyalty and bravery but here
dogs also figure in an unusual ritual
every four years the baser baby people
initiate boys into manhood the process a
series of ceremonies including
circumcision hinges on a sacrifice to
honor their ancestors and bolster their
sons courage the baser rebe kill and eat
a dog this year endo Tian will lead the
ritual the base re beloved dogs
especially dogs with brave hearts and
loyal spirits the very qualities people
here hope to absorb when they eat the
animals the soothsayer asks you to kill
a dog so that the boy won't run away in
fear
during the circumcision we don't give
names to the other animals but we give a
name to the dog because he is our
companion this dog has a name patience
for four years patience has had a good
life with his owner Seiko but Seiko has
always awaited the day of reckoning I
follow the tradition what our ancestors
did is what I do when we bought patience
we knew that we were heading for the
finish beneath the spreading baobab tree
stands the symbol of ancestral spirit
the fetish before villagers can eat
their share of dog they must feed the
spirit with sacrifices ATM's father will
begin the ceremony he appease those
spirit with millionnaire and chicken
blood the bird died clearly but patients
must live up to his name ritual requires
he be killed with a club in some
sacrifices suffering is what makes it
holy many in the village know and like
patience they'll miss him to kill the
dog but it is my sister's who started
the tradition Etienne offers the dog's
blood to the spirits out of respect he
leaves a piece of the tail
boys awaiting circumcision dance
readying themselves to eat the magic
meat they believe will awaken the
spirits of their ancestors before an
audience of village elders ATM follows
the preparation ritual well I don't know
animal to the spirit Etienne offers
roasted meat when we work the rest boils
everyone in the village will want a
taste of a sacrificial meal when you eat
the dog you get good health so everyone
wants to take a little bit go go
once the elders have eaten younger
villagers take their turn they hope the
dogs meat will give them the courage to
endure circumcision and now that the
initiation rite has begun the villages
dogs can rest easy at least for another
four years when the next ritual occurs